all right let's go to austin
who joins us in quincy illinois austin
how can we help hey guys how are you
doing thanks for taking my call and
thanks for all your work you're doing up
here
well thank you what's up well i was
hoping to get a little bit of guidance
or advice on whether to either
invest in some rental properties or
just in gross stock mutual funds once we
finish up baby step six
so my wife my wife and i were uh we
should be done
with baby step six by the end of this
calendar year and at that point i'd like
to
you know think about either investing in
rental properties or just go
stock mutual funds now personally i'm in
more interested in the rental properties
and my wife she's
she's a little skeptical about it which
i can understand but um
i've heard dave mentioned on the show
that a real estate
can outperform gross stock mutual funds
but i did not know if that included you
know the time
and the hassle and the maintenance
that's going to be coming along with a
rental property
yeah that's that's definitely an
additional
some factors to take in right and you
know depending upon how
many properties or whether you're
utilizing a property management company
that typically can charge seven to ten
percent it depends but let me ask you
this
austin you say invest in
um your in your real in your real estate
scenario are you getting a mortgage
and then finding a renter to pay the
mortgage or are you talking about saving
up cash
and buying the real estate well you know
the answer to that
well i gotta check on it hold on a
second don't you
testing with me hold on a second i'm
gonna slow clap for austin
austin way to throw it back austin's not
playing he's on baby step
six well i know austin all right you
all right but austin i asked that buddy
i asked that because you're absolutely
right saving up going cash
is the way to go and here's a thought
you know you thinking about that talking
about the type and the dollar amount
i think it would be a great opportunity
to talk to your wife
to help her start to see the options and
here's the thing
diversify brother save up pay cash for
the real estate
but also do some gross stock mutual
funds and you guys have a great
opportunity to be able to look at that
and maybe she's team gross stock mutual
fund
and your team real estate either way you
guys are all together but taking a look
to see which one grows
which one is outperforming the other but
i think you can't go
wrong either way and i like you being
diversified instead of being all in with
one all right so austin i'm a man of the
people so i'm going to ask a question on
your behalf to chris
all right so i got to ask austin a
question then i got a question so austin
here we go
um how long before you're able to so you
you get through baby step six when you
get there i think you said into the
calendar year
how long before you save up enough money
to buy that first
real estate property in cash
well obviously it kind of depends on
what the property i'd be looking at but
i'd probably be looking at the 75 000
range i think i could have that saved up
in
four to five years okay so that's why i
asked that question chris
because he's looking at a four to five
year process of saving
right and so that's why you gave him
advice he needs to be doing both yeah
absolutely and the reason
and so going the route even though
you're at baby step six
investing that 15 is the thing that you
are doing from henceforth and
forevermore that's right
and so the saving up for real estate
austin is going to do that over and
above
his 15. so a lot of people think well
once i get to six
i can pull that 15 and start no no no no
no both hands no you're still doing the
15
that's forever more then you start to
save and work and get up extra money to
to save toward real estate for cash yeah
all right i like it so austin there you
go the answer is both and
and you're going to save up it's going
to take you four to five years and now
you're rocking you've been
putting your money away in the gross
stock mutual funds for the entire time
and you're safe enough to buy the house
that's right love it thank you austin
yeah thanks for the call austin got
testy with me
well i you know got testy with me i feel
like you weren't listening to him he
said
i'm almost done with baby step six and
and
you think well he's using dave's
language and then you're going to ask
him a question
first of all i mean you deserve why i
said what i said
a lot of people say investing in real
estate they're talking about taking out
a mortgage card
they're taking out a mortgage and then
they have a renter and then the renter
doesn't pay
then they've got a situation i think
you're the one that's testing i
i am i think austin was just was just
giving it
i like austin's style he's a good guy
he's you know what send austin my book
send him a copy every millionaire i'm
not mad at him i respect him
since feisty so now we're going to give
austin i like you all right he's my
friend